The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
Could everyone take
10 more seconds
on the clicker question.
And as a reminder, hopefully I
don't need to remind any of
you, but exam 1 is on Wednesday,
so rather than our
clicker question being on
something from last class,
which is exam 2 material, let's
just make sure everyone
remembers some small topic from
exam 1 material, which is
the idea of angular nodes.
So I was hoping to see more like
99% on this, but you do
still have two more days
before the exam.
Remember, we're talking about
angular nodes here, so you
need to read the question
carefully.
For an angular node, we're just
talking about what the l
value is, so whatever l is
equal to is equal to the
number of angular
nodes you have.
For an f orbital, what is the
quantum number l equal to?
Three.
Good, so everyone that
recognized that probably got
the right answer of three
angular nodes here.
So let's switch to
today's notes.
Two more quick things about the
exam, the first is that
just remember on Wednesday,
don't come here, the exam is
not here, don't come here.
It's in Walker, so make
sure you go to Walker.
And also, keep in mind that
I have office hours
today from 3 to 5.
All your TA's have either
already have their extra
office hours, or there are some
that will be going on
tonight or tomorrow, so keep
those in mind as your
finishing up your studying
for the exam.
So, today we're moving on,
we're talking about Lewis
structures.
This is a really good topic to
do the class before an exam
because it's a little bit
of a lighter topic.
We remember that Lewis
structures are an idea that
are pre-quantum mechanics.
So that means that we don't
have to worry about things
like wave functions when we're
talking about Lewis
structures, but because they're
so simple to use and
because they so often predict
the electron configuration of
molecules accurately, we end up
using them all the time in
chemistry, so it's very valuable
to know how to draw
them correctly and to know
how to work with them.
So we'll talk specifically about
drawing Lewis structures
and then about formal charge
and resonance, which are
within Lewis structures.
So remember, that when we talked
about Lewis structure,
the organizing principle behind
Lewis structures is the
idea that within the molecule
the atoms are going to arrange
their valence electrons, such
that each atom within the
molecule has a complete octet
or full outer shell.
So this is the idea of the octet
rule that Lewis came up
with way back in 1902.
So, at the end of the class on
Friday, we saw that list of
eight steps that you always need
to go through when you
draw a Lewis structure.
Once you're doing this on your
own, especially, for example,
on exam 2, which is a ways down
the road, you won't be
able to look at those steps, so
you need to make sure that
you can go through them without
looking at them, but
for now we can look at them as
we are actually learning how
to draw the Lewis structures,
and rather just go through
them step-by-step, it's
more interesting to
do it with an example.
So let's hydrogen cyanide
as our first example.
So we have h c n.
So, in this example here, we
start with the first step --
the first step in any Lewis
structure is drawing the
skeletal structure.
So, essentially drawing how the
atoms are arranged within
our molecule.
And in this case we have three
choices here in terms of
what's going to be in the
middle, so we need to decide
that first.
In terms of where different
atoms are in a molecule, if
you have a hydrogen atom or a
fluorine atom, you can pretty
much guarantee they're always
going to be terminal atoms.
By terminal I mean they're
only bonded to one thing.
So, for example, hydrogen or
fluorine they'll never be in
the middle, they'll always be
on the end of a molecule.
So that takes care of the
hydrogen, what about between
the carbon and the nitrogen?
In terms of picking a Lewis
structure that's going to be
the lowest energy, what you
want to do is put the atom
with the lowest ionization
energy in the
center of your atom.
This should make sense because
if something has a low
ionization energy, that means
it's not very electronegative,
which means it's going to be a
lot happier giving up electron
density, which is essentially
what you're doing when you're
forming covalent bonds is you're
sharing some of your
electron density.
So, we keep the atoms with the
lowest ionization energy in
the center.
So, why don't you go ahead and
tell me, keeping that in mind,
which atom in terms of h c or
n would you expect to be in
the center of hydrogen
cyanide?
And I put a periodic table up
there, just the part you might
need to look at.
So this should be fast, so
let's take 10 seconds.
All right, good job everyone.
So most of you saw that carbon
should be in the center.
Carbon should be in the center
because it has the lowest
ionization energy.
We know that ionization energy
is going to increase as we go
across the periodic table, so
that means carbon has a lower
ionization energy than
nitrogen, which is
right next to us.
So as I just said, we want to
put that one in the middle.
You got an extra hint here in
terms of the order, so even if
you had just forgotten what I
said, sometimes it's not a
terrible idea just to put it
in the order it's written,
that can give you a lot
of clues as well.
So, either of those ways of
figuring this out is the first
guess of what goes in the middle
will work pretty well.
So, let's go ahead and draw our
Lewis structure based on
the rest of the rules now
that we have a skeleton.
So our skeleton tells us that
carbon is in the middle, so
we'll put the h on one
side, and the n on
the other side there.
So, our second step, as we go
through our Lewis structure
rules, is to figure out how many
valence electrons we have
in our entire molecule.
So if we talk about hydrogen,
how many valence electrons are
we talking about?
1.
What about carbon?
I heard 4 and 6.
And remember, we're only
talking about valence
electrons, so the outer-most
shells.
So we're talking about four
valence electrons for carbon.
And then for nitrogen?
Lots of options I have to
choose from from these
answers, but it's 5.
So, if you can't immediately
know, and you don't all have
periodic tables in front of you,
so that's fine, but if
you have a periodic table in
front of you, you need to be
able to count valence electrons,
so work on that if
it doesn't come naturally
to you in terms of
figuring that out.
So then in order to figure out
the complete number of valence
electrons in our molecule, we
just add 5 plus 4 plus 1.
So we end up having 10
valence electrons.
Step three in our Lewis
structure rules is to figure
out how many electronis we would
need in order for every
single atom in our molecule to
have a full valence shell.
So, if we're talking about
hydrogen, that's our one
exception so far to
the octet rule.
So we actually only need two
electrons to fill up the
valence shell of hydrogen,
remember that's because all we
need to fill up is the 1 s.
However, for carbon and nitrogen
we need 8 each.
So in terms of total numbers
that we would need to complete
our octets and fill our valence
shells, we would need
18 electrons.
All right.
So let's bring down our
middle slide here.
So we have 18 electrons, and the
next thing that we need to
figure out is how many bonding
electrons we have.
So to figure out bonding
electrons, what we take is
that number 18, which is our
total number of electrons we
need to fill valence shells,
and we subtract it from our
number of valence electrons,
which is 10.
And what we find that we have
is 8 bonding electrons.
And hopefully on your paper, you
can actually reach your h
c n skeleton --
I think I should probably
re-draw mine here.
Because step five is that we
need to fill in our bonding
electrons, and we start
it with filling in two
electrons per bond.
So I'm just going to re-draw
my skeleton.
So, the first thing we do is
put two electrons between h
and c, and then two electrons
between c and n.
Remember, every time we have two
electrons that are being
shared, that's a single bond.
The next thing that we want to
do is figure out do we have
any bonding electrons left.
So let's see, we started with
8 bonding electrons, and we
used up only 4, so the answer
is yes, we have 4 bonding
electrons left.
So what we need to do is fill
in those extra bonding
electrons into our bonds.
Should I put an extra
pair of electrons
here, does anyone think?
No.
The reason is because we already
have a full valence
shell for our hydrogen,
it doesn't
want anymore electrons.
What about between the
carbon and nitrogen?
Yes.
Definitely, because both of
these are not anywhere near
filling up their octets yet.
So we can put actually all 4
of our extra electrons in
between the carbon
and the nitrogen.
Now we have 6 things around the
nitrogen, and we have 8
around the carbon.
So, what we do as our seventh
step is then figure out if we
have any extra valence electrons
left at all.
So we started with 10 valence
electrons, we used up 8 of
those electrons in terms
of making bonds.
So it turns out that we have
2 valence electrons left.
So we need to add those 2
valence electrons left as lone
pair electrons in
our structure.
So, which atom is in need of
those lone pair electrons?
The nitrogen.
The reason being that's the only
one that didn't have a
full octet yet.
So now we're done, actually
there is one more step, which
is to determine the
formal charge.
This is a good way to actually
check if your Lewis structure
is correct or not.
We haven't actually learned how
to calculate the formal
charge yet, we'll
learn it soon.
So we won't do it for this
molecule, but we'll go back
and do it for some of our other
examples, and you can go
back and do it for this one.
The other thing is that we
can re-write our h c
n in terms of bonds.
So we know every time we have
two electrons, that's a bond.
So we have h, then we can
draw our bond as a line.
And then we have a triple bond
there because we have 3 pairs
of electrons.
So it looks a lot less messy
if we just draw our Lewis
structure like this for h c n,
where we have h bonded to c
triple, bonded to n, and
then a lone pair on
the nitrogen there.
All right, so this is the same
procedure that we're going to
go through, regardless of what
kind of Lewis structure we're
going to draw.
What you'll actually find in
terms of asking your TAs about
the Lewis structure rules is
that sometimes they won't be
as good at them as you are, and
the reason is once you've
drawn enough of these
structures, you start to get a
lot of chemical intuition about
what's right or what's
not right -- it just looks wrong
to you if it's wrong.
So your TA might take a minute,
so be patient with
them if they see your structure
and they say oh, no,
no, no, no that's wrong, that's
terrible, and they
don't immediately know why.
They might need to go through
the rules with you, you might
need to remind them.
Hopefully, they'll all
study them again, so
this will be an issue.
But what really happens is as
you go on in chemistry, you
draw so many of these you can
just draw them without
following the rules.
Some of you might get almost to
that point, or you might be
at that point now, but I
recommend this for you and for
me and for the TAs, go through
the rules because there'll be
cases where it's a little bit
tricky and it's always much
faster to have gone through
step-by-step, than to try to
just kind of hit or miss figure
out what's going to be
right or wrong.
So, let's try another example
here, and let's try a case now
where instead of dealing with a
neutral molecule we have an
ion, so we have c n minus.
And what I'll mention to you
just in terms of the fact that
we're finally dealing with real
molecules, which is -- or
molecules that are made up of
more than one atom, which is
kind of exciting for me and
maybe for some other of you
that like to move into thinking
about what some of
the consequences of these
molecules reacting might be.
A lot of the examples that we're
going to give you in
terms of trying out your Lewis
structures will be molecule
that are used in organic
synthesis, or maybe they're
molecules that react in
interesting ways with
biomolecules in your body or
proteins in your body.
So, you already will have a head
start when you get on to
later classes, like organic
chemistry or if you're
thinking about biochemistry
where being able to draw the
Lewis structure allows you to
think about, eventually, the
reactivity of the molecule,
which becomes very interesting
in thinking about how you're
going to synthesize a more
complex molecule, or how that
molecule is going to interact
with an active site in a
protein in the body.
So, for example, just talking
about hydrogen cyanide or the
cyanide anion, these are both
molecules which are used in
organic synthesis, so
particularly the cyanide,
anion and salts of the
cyanide anion.
So either a potassium cyanide
or sodium cyanide, these are
used in synthesis in terms of
making carbon-carbon bonds.
So if you're trying to make
a more complicated organic
molecule, carbon-carbon bonds
are one of the most difficult
things to make an organic
chemistry, and it turns out
that c n minus is a very
reactive molecule, so it's a
good way, even though we'll go
over some drawbacks in a
second, it is a good way to
make carbon-carbon bonds.
It's very reactive.
And because, of course, we have
this carbon here what you
end up doing is adding a carbon
to your molecule.
So, when you think about
cyanide, you might not think
about organic reagents.
Does anyone have something else
they think about when
they think about cyanide?
STUDENT: Death.
PROFESSOR: Death -- that's
a good thought.
Yes, cyanide and death, very
closely related as well.
Cyanide is incredibly toxic,
it's a poison.
That might be how you're more
familiar with cyanide.
So if you're working with
cyanide in the lab as
potassium cyanide or sodium
cyanide, those are what are
called p h s's, or particularly
hazardous
substances -- it's a rating for
different kinds of chemicals.
And what that means it's
there's all sorts of
precautions and procedures you
take that are special when you
deal with these.
They're kept away from
other chemicals.
You handle them very special
in terms of being extra
careful in a very high
ventilation area, in hoods is
how you handle them.
So, yes, they're very poisonous,
and in fact, there
are areas where you find this
toxic compound, cyanide.
Other than just in poisons and
in organic synthesis shells,
you might also find them in
some things we're more
familiar with, such
as almonds.
I don't know how many know that
there are trace , trace
amounts, of cyanide
in almonds.
I don't know if there any big
almond eaters out there.
You don't have to worry, we're
definitely talking about
trace, trace amounts.
It's not going to hurt you.
And actually, what we usually
eat are what are called sweet
almonds, and there aren't actual
cyanide in the sweet
almonds we eat, there's
precursors to cyanide, which
might not make you
more comfortable.
But the fact is there are
trace, trace amounts.
This is nothing that we need to
worry in our food supply.
However, some people
aren't so lucky.
I don't know how many of you are
familiar with the Cassava
plant, which is a kind of woody
shrub that's first been
cultivated in South America,
but it's grown throughout
Africa, the Caribbean, South
America still, many places
around the world, and this
is a major source of
carbohydrates for much of the
world, because Cassava root is
very, very rich in
carbohydrates.
It's not the best form of food
in that they're actually very
poor in protein, and
unfortunately very, very rich
in cyanide.
So, these roots can
be very dangerous.
There's different types of the
root that you can get called
the bitter and the sweet.
Hopefully you would all choose
the sweet if two are put in
front of you.
The bitter, of course,
are the ones that are
very high in cyanide.
If you eat these raw, which they
do in many places around
the world, if you eat a bitter
one, you could, in fact, get
enough cyanide to kill you.
And there are ways to prepare
these, so it's important --
this kind of thinking more along
the food science idea.
There's a way to actually grind
down and prepare the
flower, so that you promote the
enzymes within the plant
to breakdown the cyanide
precursors.
And if you put this in the
well-ventilated area, if you
prepare this outside, the h
c n gas will actually be
released into the air,
so you're safe,
you can eat it later.
About 80% of the cyanide at that
point is gone, so it does
render the root much
more safe.
But you do, in fact, have
to worry about long-term
exposure, cyanide poisoning in
terms of long-term effects in
certain populations that do
get the bulk of their
carbohydrates from this
root, from the root
of the Cassava plant.
But in terms of us going to the
grocery store and thinking
about things, probably we're all
breathing sighs of relief.
I just told you almonds
are not a
problem, no worries there.
We probably don't find any forms
of the Cassava plant
ever in the U.S. that are
going to have that high
cyanide content, so we should
all be relieved.
Unless, of course, you're a
smoker, or you're thinking of
becoming a smoker, and then
maybe you should worry,
because this is one of the
advertisements that was airing
in terms of anti-smoking
campaign.
Hydrogen cyanide is found
in cigarettes.
So, if you're looking for
another reason to quit, if
you're looking for a reason not
to start smoking, here's
another good one.
As I said, it's a particularly
hazardous substance, this is
worked with in fume hoods.
You don't want to inhale
it, it's definitely not
recommended.
The way, in the simplest terms
that cyanide can kill you, is
it basically out-competes
your oxygen for the
heme in your blood.
So instead of carrying oxygen to
your cells, you're carrying
cyanide to your cells.
Obviously, the amounts that
are in cigarettes are not
enough that people are dropping
dead of cyanide
poisoning, but still it's not
a good idea if you can avoid
eating or inhaling cyanide
-- you definitely want to
minimize your exposure.
And in terms of thinking about
it for organic chemistry or if
you're interested in thinking
about the mechanism maybe by
which it is toxic, a first
step would be to draw its
Lewis structure.
So, let's go ahead and make sure
we can draw that, if we
have interest either in the area
of organic chemistry or
biochemistry or biology here.
So in terms of the first step of
skeletal structure, this is
actually going to be easier
because we don't have a
central atom, we just have
carbon and nitrogen here.
Our next step is thinking
about valence electrons.
So we have 4 plus 5, but we're
actually not done yet, because
it's c n minus, so if we have
minus, we actually have an
extra electron in
our molecule.
So we need to add 1 more.
If instead we had a positive
ion, a cation, what we would
have to do is subtract 1.
But here we're going to
add 1, so again, we
have 10 valence electrons.
And if we go on to step three
where we figure out how many
we would need for full octets,
it's just going to be 2 times
8, so we have 16.
And step four is going to have
us figure out how many bonding
electrons we have, so we have 16
minus 10, is going to be 6
bonding electrons.
So, step five tells us to add 2
electrons between each atom,
so we add two there.
And step six asks us,
well, do we have any
bonding electrons left?
So how many bonding electrons
do we have left?
Yup, so we do, we have 4 left.
We started with 6,
we only used 2.
This is very easy molecule
because we know exactly where
to put them without even having
to think, we only have
one option, and we'll make a
triple bond between the carbon
and the nitrogen.
So, seven asks us if we have
any valence electrons left,
and how many valence electrons
do we have left?
Yeah, so also 4.
We started with 10 valence
electrons, we used up 6 of
those as bonding electrons, so
we have 4 left, which will be
lone pair electrons.
So, in order to fill our octet,
what we do is put two
on the nitrogen and
two on the carbon.
So, in terms of finishing our
Lewis structure, we're
actually not done yet here,
even though we have full
octets, and we've used up all of
our valence electrons, and
the reason is because it's c n
minus, so we need to make sure
that that's reflected in our
Lewis structure, so let's put
it in brackets here,
and put a minus 1.
And also I wanted to mention
in terms of checking your
Lewis structures, regardless of
what they are, you should
always go back and say
how many valence
electrons did I have --
I had 10, and then count 2, 4,
6, 8, 10, because you always
need to make sure you have the
same number of valence
electrons that you calculated
in your actual structure.
That'll catch a lot of just
silly mistakes for you if you
go back and see it and you
don't have all of that.
Let's re-draw this, so it looks
a little bit neater,
where we have a triple bond in
the middle instead, and again,
we need our negative
1 charge there.
And our eigth step in the
process, again, is formal
charge, which we will talk
about very soon.
All right.
So let's try one more example
of drawing Lewis structures
before we talk about
formal charge.
And the last example that we're
going to talk about is
thionyl chloride, so
it's s o c l 2.
This is another good step
forward, because now we
actually have four different
atoms in our molecule.
I'll tell you a little about
thionyl chloride as well.
This is another organic
chemistry reagent, it's also
used extensively in the
pharmaceutical industry.
And what it's used is to convert
one type of group,
what's called a carboxylic acid
into another type of very
reactive intermediate, which
is called an acid chloride.
So I show that here, so in
green, you have what's called
a carboxcylic acid group, a c o
o h, which gets converted by
s o c l 2 to a c double bond
o c l or an acid chloride.
This is the very reactive
intermediate.
You'll learn a lot more about
this if you take organic
chemistry, but, In fact, you
can then go on and make a
bunch of other different kinds
of very interesting molecules.
So, for example, this is the
synthesis of novacaine.
This is what's used
in industry to
actually make novacaine.
Has anyone had a novacaine
procedure?
Yes.
I've had it also many times,
you usually get
novacaine for cavities.
There's some alternatives that
are used now as well.
It's also used as a local
anesthetic for other types of
small procedures.
So, this is, in fact,
what's used to make
novacaine in industry.
You'll notice that a lot of
different kinds medications do
you have chlorine in them,
you'll see that c l group.
So, for example, you might be
familiar with Wellbutrin here,
this is a type of
anti-depressant that a lot of
people use right now that are
taking anti-depressants.
It's on the market, very popular
in terms of your
choices right now as an option
as an anti-depressant.
Also, Lunesta.
This was very big in an ad
campaign at least last year,
I'm not sure if it still is,
with the little butterfly.
This is the structure of
Lunesta, and you see the c l
in it as well.
I just wanted to point out that
although you see these
chlorine atoms in these drugs,
what you almost never see is
an acid chloride -- in fact, I
don't think I've ever seen an
acid chloride in a final
pharmaceutical product or drug
that we take, and the reason is
because they're so reactive
that you wouldn't want to have
that in something you digest.
So just keep in mind when you
do see the chlorine in these
drugs, it's very different
from the acid chloride.
So, for example, Wellbutrin,
it is very unlikely that it
would have thionyl chloride in
order to make it, and if
thionyl chloride was used at
some point in the synthesis,
it was not to put that chlorine
atom on, it was to
put something else on.
But in terms of drugs that don't
look like maybe this
compound was used in the
synthesis, many of them might
have used thionyl chloride,
because it generates such a
nice reactive intermediate that
you can go on and make a
bunch of different compounds
from that intermediate.
All right.
So let's think about how to draw
the Lewis structure for
thionyl chloride -- oh,
actually, let me let you tell
me how we should start
this Lewis structure.
So, which atom would you expect
to be in the center of
a Lewis structure for
thionyl chloride?
All right.
Let's take 10 seconds on that.
Looks like we have some fast
thinking here, a lot of last
minute answers coming in.
OK.
We have a split decision, so
-- you know what, actually,
let's think about this
for a second.
So hopefully, it was a time
issue in terms of looking at
the periodic table, because
let's have you tell me what
are we looking for here?
Yeah.
OK.
We're looking for the lowest
ionization energy.
So, this one can be tricky
because oxygen looks like it's
in the middle because of the way
it's written, but we need
to start by looking at the
lowest ionization energy.
So, if we look on the periodic
table, comparing, for example,
s to o, if we have s it's
below o, what happens to
ionization energy as
we go down a table?
It decreases.
If you're still not completely
up on the periodic trends,
that is stuff that's going to be
on the first exam, so make
sure that you're able to do this
without taking too much
time to think about it.
We would expect the ionization
energy to decrease, that means
that sulfur has our lowest
ionization energy.
All right.
So, let's go ahead and draw our
Lewis structure here with
sulfur in the middle.
So, we can put our sulfur in
the middle, and then it
doesn't really matter how we
draw the rest of it, where we
put our c l's versus where
we put our oxygens.
We'll just put them in some way
around our sulfur atom.
So that's our step one.
For our step two,
what we need is
number of valence electrons.
So we have 2 for each
of the chlorine.
How many valence electrons
are in chlorine?
All right.
So it's 7 that are in chlorine,
it's the same as
fluorine or any of the
others in that row or
in that group rather.
2 times 7, plus we have 6 in
the sulfur, and oxygen is
right above sulfur, so
that also has 6.
So we end up having 26 valence
electrons that we're
dealing with here.
Our step three is to figure out
how many bonding electrons
that we need, or excuse me, how
many total electrons that
we need to fill up our octets,
so that's just going to be 4
times 8, which is 32.
And then we take 32 minus 26.
So what we end up with in terms
of our bonding electrons
is going to be 6 bonding
electrons.
So we can go right ahead
and fill these in.
1 2, 3 4, 5 and 6.
And that was step five.
Step six is thinking about
do we have any
bonding electrons left?
Nope, we used them all up.
So we don't need to put any
more bonds in there.
And step seven is how many
electrons do we have left over
that are going to go
into lone pairs?
How many?
20.
26 minus 6, so that tells us 20,
and these are all going to
be lone pairs.
Well, we're talking about a
pretty high number here, so to
make counting easier, we'll
just say 10 lone pairs,
because 20 lone pair electrons
is the same
thing as 10 lone pairs.
And all we need to do
is go over here now
and fill up our octets.
So oxygen gets 3 pairs, and each
chlorine gets 3 pairs, so
now we're up to 9 pairs.
And what we have left here is
the sulfur, which will also
get a pair.
So, if you look at all of these,
we have full octets for
all of them, and if we count
up all of the valence
electrons, it's going to be
equal to our number 26 here.
And the last thing we do for any
of our structures to check
them and figure out are these
valid or not valid, are these
good Lewis structures is to
check the formal charge.
So now that we have enough
practice drawing Lewis
structures, let's talk about
actually figuring out this
formal charge.
So when we talk about formal
charge, basically formal
charge is the measure of the
extent to which an individual
atom within your molecule
has either
gained or lost an electron.
So as we said when we first
introduced covalent bonds,
it's a sharing of electrons,
but it's not
always an equal sharing.
Sometimes we have a very
electronegative atom that's
going to take more of its equal
share of electron density.
So for example, that might
have a formal charge of
negative 1, because to some
extent it has gained that much
electron density that
it now has a formal
charge that's negative.
So, when we think about any
type of formal charges, we
have to assign these based on a
formula here, which is very
easy to follow.
Formal charge equals v
minus l minus 1/2 s.
It's even easier to follow
if we know what all
of those stand for.
So, f c, I think you all
know is formal charge.
Does anyone have
a guess for v?
Everyone has a guess, great.
Valence electrons.
What about l?
Lone pairs.
So, lone pair electrons,
actually, not lone pairs
themselves.
And then s?
Good.
That's a tricky one,
shared electrons.
All right.
So this means we can actually
calculate this for any
molecule that we've drawn the
Lewis structure for, because
we actually do need to draw the
Lewis structure before we
know, for example, how many of
each of these we have, or at
least go through the rules.
And what's important to keep in
mind about formal charge is
if we have a neutral atom,
such as we did in thionyl
chloride here, the sum of the
individual formal charges on
individual atoms within the
molecule have to equal 0.
So if we add them all up, there
should be no net charge
on the molecule, if the
molecule is neutral.
So, if we think about the second
case here where we have
c n minus, now we're talking
about a molecule with a net
charge of negative 1.
So that means if we add up all
of the formal charges within
the molecule, what we would
expect to see is that they sum
up to give a net charge
of negative 1.
So we can do this for any final
charge we have, if we a
molecule that has a charge of
plus 2, then all of the formal
charges should add up
to plus 2 and so on.
So, let's just figure this out
for some of the examples we
did, so for the cyanide anion.
So, if we want to figure out
the formal charge on the
carbon, we need to take the
number of valence electrons,
so that's 4.
We need to subtract the lone
pair, what number is that?
It's 2.
And then 1/2 of the number
of shared electrons.
So, shared electrons are the
ones that are shared between
the carbon and the nitrogen, so
we have 6 shared electrons,
and we want to take
1/2 of that.
So we end up with a
formal charge on
carbon of negative 1.
We can do the same thing
for nitrogen.
So in terms of nitrogen that
starts off with a valence
number of 5, again we have 2
lone pair electrons in the
nitrogen, and again, we have 6
electrons that are shared.
So what we see is that
the formal charge on
the nitrogen is 0.
Also, formal charges can be
checked, as I just said.
Negative 1 plus 0 should add up
to negative 1, if in fact,
we're correct for
the c n anion.
And it does, so we know that
we're probably on target in
terms of calculating
our formal charge.
So, let's think about our second
example -- actually our
third, but the second one we're
going to talk about in
terms of formal charge, which
is thionyl chloride.
So why don't you tell me what
the formal charge should be on
the sulfur atom of
thionyl chloride?
All right.
Let's take 10 more seconds.
OK, so the majority got it.
So hopefully next time we do a
formal charge question, we'll
get everyone back up to speed.
But we've just introduced it, so
let's go back to the class
notes and explain why this
is the correct answer.
So if we look at sulfur, what
we need to do is take the
valence electrons in sulfur,
and there are 6.
By looking at the periodic table
it's right underneath
oxygen, so those both have
6 valence electrons.
There are 2 lone pair electrons
on sulfur -- we only
have 2 lone pairs -- or 1 lone
pair, 2 lone pair electrons.
And then we end up having 6
shared electrons, 2 from each
of the bonds, so we end up
with a formal charge on
sulfur of plus 1.
If we go to the oxygen atom,
now we're talking about
starting with 6 in terms of
valence electrons again, but
instead of 2, you can see we
have 6 lone pair electrons
around the oxygen minus 1/2 of
2, so we have minus 1 is our
formal charge.
And if we talk about chlorine,
and both of the chlorines are
the same in this case, we start
with a valence number of
7 for chlorine, and then we
subtract 6, because it had 6
lone pair electrons around each
of the chlorine atoms.
Then minus 1/2 of 2, because
we only have one bond or 2
electrons in a bond.
So again, we should be able
to check all of our formal
charges and make sure they add
up to 0, which they do, and
that makes sense, because we
have a neutral atom in terms
of thionyl chloride.
Another thing to mention in
terms of thinking about if you
have a good or a bad Lewis
structure, is that when you
figure out the formal charge on
each of the atoms, it's the
more electronegative atoms that
you would expect to have
that negative charge, and that
should make sense to you
because electronegative atoms
want to have electron density,
they want to pull in electron
density to them, so it would
make sense that they have more
of it, which would give them a
negative charge.
So, if we compare the sulfur to
the oxygen, the oxygen it
turns out is more
electronegative and that is
what holds the negative charge
in this molecule.
Another thing I want to point
out, and for some of you just
ignore what I'm saying, if
you haven't thought about
oxidation number, if you haven't
heard of that before,
don't worry we'll get to
it in the second half
with Professor Drennan.
But for those of you from high
school that have learned about
oxidation number and maybe are
starting to think about it
when you look at these
molecules, formal charge is --
it's not the same thing as
oxidation number, so separate
those two things in your head.
We'll get to oxidation number
in the second half of this
course, but it's not
in any way the same
idea as formal charge.
All right.
So formal charge can actually
help us out when we're trying
to decide between several Lewis
structures that look
like they might be comparable in
terms of which might be the
lower energy or the more
stable structure.
The examples we've done so
far have been pretty
straightforward, so we haven't
needed to use formal charge to
make this kind of decision.
But we could, for example, look
at a case where we have
several different structures
that look pretty good, and the
one we want to determine as
being the lowest energy
structure is the one in which
the absolute values of the
formal charges are going to be
lower, so essentially that
they have less charge
separation.
Those are going to be the more
stable or the lower energy
structures.
So, for example, let's look
at thiocyanate ion, we
have c s and n.
What we've learned so far is as
a first approximation, what
we want to do is put the atom
with the lowest ionization
energy in the middle here.
So let's compare those
ionization energies.
We have 10 90 for carbon, 1,000
for sulfur, and 1,400
for nitrogen.
So, thinking about ionization
energy, which atom would you
put in the middle here?
So, a lot of people
I hear are saying
sulfur, and that's right.
So, in terms of ionization
energy, we would expect to see
sulfur in the middle.
So if we went through and drew
out our Lewis structure
following each of our steps,
what we would get is this as
our Lewis structure here, and we
could figure out all of the
formal charges.
But what I'm going to tell you
already is this is a case
where, in fact, it's an
exception to the idea that the
lowest energy structure has the
lowest ionization energy
in the middle, and we can figure
this out when we look
at formal charge.
It's always a good first
approximation, because you
need to start somewhere in
terms of drawing Lewis
structures, but then if you go
and figure out the formal
charge and you just have lots
of charge separation or very
high charges, like a plus 2 and
a minus 2 and a minus 1
all different places in the
atom, what it should tell you
is maybe there's a
better structure.
So, let's think of all of the
combinations that we could
have in terms of
this molecule.
So in one case, we could
actually put carbon in the
middle, in one place, we could
put sulfur in the middle, and
in one case we could
put nitrogen.
And then we can go ahead and
let's quickly write out what
the formal charges for
all of these will be.
So in our first structure, we
would find for the nitrogen we
have a formal charge 5 minus
4 minus 2, because we're
starting with 5 valence
electrons, so that is a formal
charge of minus 1.
For the carbon, we start with 4
valence electrons, we have 0
lone pair electrons minus 4,
and we end up with a formal
charge of 0.
For the sulfur, we start off
with 6 valence electrons,
minus 4 lone pair electrons,
minus 2, taking in account our
bonding electrons, so we end up
with a formal charge of 0.
All right, so this looks
pretty good.
We don't actually have much
charge separation
in this case here.
Let's take a look at the lowest
ionization energy in
the center case.
And what you find out if you do
these calculations, is that
you have a negative 1 for your
formal charge on nitrogen, you
have a negative 2 for your
formal charge on carbon, and
you have a positive 2 for your
formal charge on sulfur.
If we look at our last structure
here where we have
nitrogen the middle, we can
also figure out all those
formal charges, and in this
case we have plus 1 on the
nitrogen, we have minus 2 on the
carbon, and then we end up
with a 0 on the sulfur there.
So let's go to a clicker
question.
If we call this structure a,
b, and c -- you can look on
your notes, it also says
structure a, b, and c on your
notes, so you didn't
need to have just
memorized that slide.
But I want you to tell me in
terms of thinking about formal
charge, which Lewis structure
would you predict to be the
most stable?
And this should be fast, so
let's take 10 seconds on this.
Okay, great.
So let's go back to
our notes here.
And the reason that this
should be so fast is we
already did all the
calculations
for the formal charges.
So what we see is that structure
a is the most stable
because we have the least
separation of charge in the
case of structure a.
And you can do this any time if
you have Lewis structures
that you're choosing between.
You won't always draw out every
single possibility that
you have to start with.
Often a good thing to start
with is to put the lowest
ionization energy atom in the
middle, and if you don't have
charge separation then go with
that structure, but if you do
find you have a lot of
separation, such as the case
in negative 2, positive 2, and
minus 1, then you want to say
wait a second, this is really
bad in terms of formal charge,
let me go ahead and see what
other options I have here.
So, we can also get into a case
where we have similar
values in terms of absolute
values of formal charge
between two different molecules
we're deciding
between in their Lewis
structures.
And in this case, the
tie-breaker goes to the
molecule in which the negative
charge is on the most
electronegative atom.
So, let's look at an example
of this here.
So we could say, for example,
this molecule here, this --
now we're dealing with a lot
of different atoms in the
molecule, much more complicated
than the initial
case of the cyanide ion
where we only had two.
So, how do we figure out first
how to draw the skeletal
structure of this
molecule here?
And one thing I want to tell
you to start out with is
something about this
c h 3 group here.
Any time you see a c h 3, this
means a methyl group.
And if you draw out what a
methyl group is -- hopefully
you won't have to spell it --
then what you have is a carbon
in the middle with three
hydrogens around it, and then
it can only be bonded
to one other thing.
So any time you see c h 3 here,
remember that that's
methyl and that's going to
be a terminal group.
So, you already have a hint that
methyl groups are never
in the middle, they always have
to be on the outside.
So that's a good start for us
putting together a skeletal
structure for this
compound here.
The other tip I'm going to give
you is any time you see a
chain molecule, by chain I just
mean many different atoms
written out in a row.
A convention is that typically
you will put a terminal atom.
We know that h is always
terminal, it's always on the
end, never in the center.
Right after the molecule
that it's attached to.
So, for instance, this would
suggest to us by the way it's
written, that the hydrogen is
attached to the nitrogen and
not the oxygen.
So, if we use those two tips
to try to figure out a
structure, a skeletal structure,
we would get this
structure here if we write out
the full Lewis structure.
We could I think well, maybe
this isn't written out in
terms of that convention, which
sometimes it's not, so
let's also try writing it, such
that we have the hydrogen
and the oxygen atom there.
So that would give us
this structure here.
So notice a difference in these
structures, is this has
an n h bond whereas this
has an o h bond.
And if we were to think about
which one of these is better,
it turns out that it's the
same in terms of formal
charges, so that doesn't
help us out.
So we need to go to this
second case where we're
instead going to think about
electronegativity, and we want
to think about which atom is
the most electronegative.
So, in this case, we see that
our formal charge is negative
on the nitrogen, in this case
it's negative on oxygen.
Which of those two is more
electronegative?
The oxygen.
So you should be able to look at
your periodic table and see
this, or also I've written
the trend here.
So that means that the more
stable molecule is going to be
this molecule here, which
actually puts the negative
charge on be more
electronegative atom.
So this is our lower
energy structure.
So, these are the different ways
that we can actually go
ahead and use formal charge when
we're choosing between
different types of
Lewis structures.
So one last concept that I want
introduces is this idea
of resonance.
And resonance is the idea that
sometimes one single Lewis
structure does not adequately
describe the electron
configuration around a given
molecule, so instead you need
to draw two different Lewis
structures to describe that
more appropriately.
So, let's quickly go through the
Lewis structure for ozone.
I have the skeletal structure
written up there, I've written
it twice and you'll see
why in a minute.
It's easy to write the skeletal
structure, because
it's all oxygen, we don't have
to worry about what's going to
go in the middle.
In this case, we're going to
have 3 times 6 for valence
electrons --
6 valence electrons for each
oxygen, so we have 18 total
valence electrons.
So, in order to fill up our
shell, what we need is 3 times
8 or 24 electrons.
This leaves us with
24 minus 18, or 6
bonding electrons left.
So what we can do is
fill that in here.
Clearly, we put 2 for each bond,
and now we end up having
2 remaining bonding
electrons left.
So here is where our question
comes, because
where do we put it?
There's absolutely nothing that
tells us which atoms we
should put it between, because
they're both oxygen-oxygen.
So, let's just arbitrarily put
it between these two in this
case here, but actually there's
no reason we couldn't
also put it between oxygen b
and c, so I'm going to draw
another structure where
we have it here.
So in terms of remaining valence
electrons we have 12,
so we can finish off each of
our Lewis structures, so
that's our first structure
there, and our second
structure there.
We could also figure out the
formal charges, and obviously
the formal charges between these
two atoms, they're going
to be identical, we're
only dealing with
oxygen atoms here.
So, we need to think about what
this means -- which is
the more stable structure,
because we have two different
structures here.
In this case we have a double
bond between a and b, and in
this case we have it
between b and c.
So, presumably, if we follow our
rules so far only one of
these should be correct.
And again, if we figure out the
formal charges, let's go
through this quickly, we get
0 plus 1 and negative 1 for
structure 1.
We get negative 1 plus 1
and 0 for structure 2.
So as I said, they're going to
be identical in terms of
making the decision that way.
And what it turns out is
experimental evidence tells us
that these two structures
are equivalent.
And by that what we mean is
that they're absolutely
identical, and it turns out that
this here is not a double
bond, it's not a single bond
either, it's actually
something in between.
So if we look at its length,
it's actually shorter than a
single bond, but longer
than a double bond.
Or if we look at how strong it
is, it's actually stronger
than a single bond, but weaker
than a double bond.
And we find the same thing for
these two atoms here, it's not
actually a double bond, it's
somewhere between a single
bond and a double bond.
So this is a case where we have
resonance structures, or
we call this a resonance
hybrid.
So the reality of the situation
is that it's a
combination between these
2 structures.
And an important thing to
remember when we talk about
resonance hybrids is that the
structure it's not 1/2 the
time this structure, and 1/2
of the time this structure,
it's actually some combination
or some average between the
two structures.
But since in drawing Lewis
structures we don't have a way
to represent that -- actually,
in some cases you do, you can
draw a dotted line that means a
1 and 1/2 bond, but most in
most cases, we just draw out
both resonance structures, and
the way that we say it's a
resonance structure is that we
put it in the brackets and we
put an arrow between it.
So, when you think about
resonance structures, some
students tend to just get
confused and be picturing this
flickering back and forth.
A good example to keep in mind
is the idea of a mule.
So most of you know, hopefully,
that a mule is a
combination of a donkey
and a horse.
A mule is not spending 1/2 of
its time as a donkey, and 1/2
of its time as a horse, we don't
see it flickering back
and forth between the two,
that's not what we see.
Instead what we see is it's an
average, it's part like a
horse, it's part
like a donkey.
So if we want to put that in
chemical terms, we want to
make sure we put these in
brackets here, and remember,
this is the resonance arrow,
it's not a reaction arrow,
it's a resonance arrow, so
make sure you mark it up
correctly like that.
When we talk about resonance
structures, the key word is
that the electrons
are de-localized.
So they're not just between
two atoms here.
Now, for example, in our
structure with ozone it's
between all three atoms.
And the final point I want to
make today, and this is very,
very important, so make sure
that you do understand this.
When we talk about resonance
structures, we're talking
about cases that have the same
arrangement of atoms, the key
is the atoms are the same, and
the thing that is different is
the arrangement of
electrons here.